こんにちははじめ社長とああああ破りてるんだーっ
ヤバイ人じゃやっちゃうから行っちゃっフリスビー行ったことありますか
[音楽]
はいはっはっはっクリス有効な格好でだけですがあるんですけどもそれの世界記録を
調べてみました
人間が世界一遠くに投げられる物体 a ロビーというフリスビーがあるんですけども
リスミーの世界記録は406点29メートル
ギョンヘッドの400メートルでその世界一遠くに飛ぶために使われたフリース b か
今買ってありますを持って来るため立海ちょっとぶりに向かいました
ええええええ
[音楽]
まあこういう感じねエアロ b 2回ております arab pro 400って書い
てる奴が問題400m 食べからよりって書いてあるのかなこれは人間の力だけで最も
遠くへ飛ぶリング
なんだってまぁまぁまぁちょっとあの子の腕毛が気になるところなんですけども
すごいねほんとにめっちゃと裏シーンですよ実際
ちょっと遊んでみましょうはいうんっ
俺甘いはいおれ前ですよ
バーダックんっ
ん
めっちゃ y フラインスよ
パパン意見本宮ピンは
よ
rar
持っ
えええっは山々や今見ましたもう年が見えるかな
このレベルまで飛んできました
[音楽]
dee
ああああああん
ん
ワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
par ああああああああ
愛と勇気で何回か遊んでみたんですけども飛ぶねちょっとかなり飛ぶ音外なんですけど
もうただこれでは二部ではなく
な世界生きるが406m ですねこそ
小島氏は越せる
[音楽]
矢部ないここで150m のですけど多分ずうメートルくらいですけどね
この芝生公園多分160m
the なん
するよとレーズン160名という所まっされな世界記録ができる場所ではないという
マットプレイてて masa
よく考えて右 sb で軸60メートル超こと自体教委で触れず400m
ないんですけどが今回はプレテストみたいなもんだねと場所がないんでとりあえず今
出来る最大限の160メートルを目指しテレカ1そのフリスビーだけてみたいと思い
ます
あっあーっ僕が今出来る最大限の力を示そうと思いますではいけます
もう一発決めるからできれば
dee
おっ位
三好なっちゃいましたん
me
ん
[音楽]
方だったカメラでを得ないっていう
見づらいんですよ上行っちゃうとたら行く時したで攻めるよ
了解です
[音楽]
うん
ええええええ
[音楽]
で結構扉するんですけど風邪かな幸福んですよね100m ため言ってると思うんです
けども
160はなかなか行かないです
voodoo
とっている
ん
中田も無理です
ここで飽きられていいのかよもっと上の目標があるんだろう
そうだろん
そうですねうーん
まだ諦めの早いそれだぞ
みましょう
15分
うぉ
[音楽]
踊った
dj
ee
ていません
[音楽]
me
ni
そして最後の二重
僕は全力を尽くしに投げたら最後のクリス日は
そらおと罰地面を走りめぐっと
踊った
どんどん彼はあっ
持ち主のほっ
帰ったのであっ
すいません
[音楽]
me
rar
[音楽]
だだ1回超えましたよねマジでここじゃ入ってるね
入ってますいいんじゃね